ils vivent parfois au bord des routes
nationales pas forcément moins de paris
mais toujours loin de ceux qui les
dirigent leur vie ressemble assez peu à
ce qu'on voit à la télé ils ont le
sentiment d'être des français de seconde
zone comme s'ils étaient invisibles ces
français ne veulent plus tard ils ont
des choses à dire la france oubliée
c'est une rencontre avec ces citoyens
qui ne se résignent pas à la fatalité
la france humiliée s'est montré ce qu'on
ne voit jamais
aujourd'hui je me rends à douarnenez
dans le finistère pour y rencontrer
yolande tapissière d'ameublement qui a
été tiré au sort en 2019
pour participer à la convention
citoyenne pour le climat
[Musique]
je
alors ici on est au village des
plomarc'h c1
un ancien village de pêcheurs et c'est
un endroit que j'aime bien j'aime bien
me promener ici tu es très engagé dans
l'écologie oui la sensibilité au respect
de l'environnement est ressassé depuis
super longtemps donc le hasard faisant
bien les choses
tu as été tirés au sort pour la
convention citoyenne et ouais et j'y
croyais pas franchement je trouvais que
cette convention
elle réunissait à la fois pour moi le
sujet de l'écologie qui est un sujet qui
me passionne de plus en plus de toute
façon puisque il est l'urgence
climatique
aujourd'hui on peut pas la nier qui
réunissait aussi la démocratie c'est un
des combats
franchement c'est vraiment un sujet sur
lequel je me bats et je milite et c'est
à dire une démocratie plus participative
même j'aime pas trop le mot participatif
direct direct
et puis réunis c'est aussi pour moi la
justice sociale donc vraiment trois
combats pour moi c'était trois combats
réunis et donc tu as participé aux
travaux et là pendant neuf mois j'ai
participé aux travaux la faire des
propositions
combien de proposition soit 149 65 ans
encore avant le président la république
dit j'en retiens un chiffre astronomique
ouais en fait il à 1143 joker voilà
voilà trois joker et puis là on a écarté
une c'était plus drôle des 143 ou 146
sont ces propositions sont déjà toutes
appliquées pas du tout loin de là le web
là ce qu'on est en train de constater
actuellement c'est que l'engagement de
macron du président de la république sur
le sens le côté sans filtre et un jeu
wii votre vos propositions seront
retransmises sans filtre déjà ça il
s'est assis dessus parce qu'en fait ça
arrive au parlement c'est déjà retoqué
quoi manger rénale exemple le 29 juin
on rencontre on remet nos travaux m nl
mâcon emmanuel macron fait son discours
après en disant moi je me suis dans son
discours c'était vous
vous proposez si vous proposez ça mais
allons-y agissons faisons le hockey et
il s'engage notamment sur le moratoire
de la 5g que nous ont proposé dans vos
mesures ils s'engagent là dessus le
lendemain panier rue nash est présente à
l'assemblée nationale la mise aux
enchères des réseaux pour le mois de
septembre donc géré c'est hallucinant
quoi la veille s'engage le lendemain un
de ses ministres
amen double des voix là et là je dis
mais c'est pas possible là c'est le
foutage de gueule total moi pas ou alors
ils se sont pas concertés mais bon faut
enfin je suis on n'apprend pas à un
vieux singe à faire des grimaces quoi la
convention citoyenne elle a été mise en
place à la demande des jurys citoyens ni
les citoyens qui sont eux mêmes issus
des gilet jaune
enfin en partie voilà et qui donc les
gillis rien sont pas les voir macro et
ont demandé la mise en place vont
proposer et macro il a fait qu'accepter
mais il a accepté parce que ça lui
servait et puis on puisse leur remet un
petit peu avec de la démocratie ce qu'il
a fait la démocratie délibérative
mais bon ça me satisfait pas je veux
dire je sais très bien que évidemment
dans la mesure où macron à accepter ça
on pouvait pas demander n'importe quel
interlocuteur pour les citoyens même si
on fait une convention citoyenne
organisée par un gouvernement quel qu'il
soit il faut absolument qu'il y ait dans
cette convention citoyenne la
possibilité pour les gens qui
participent d'amener eux mêmes des
interlocuteurs c'est à dire de proposer
les interlocuteurs et que ça se soit pas
systématiquement gérer contrôler par la
gouvernance qui est une gouvernance
politique pour moi c'était une
gouvernance politique quoi voilà et ça
c'est possible si c'est effectivement
une commence au citoyen organisé par des
citoyens eux mêmes qui disent voilà on
organise commençe citoyenne et
maintenant on va débattre plusieurs
citoyens
enfin avec beaucoup de citoyens ont fait
des débats contradictoires on invite des
gens de plusieurs on entend tout le
monde on n'entend pas les lobbys parce
que nous à la convention citoyenne
on a eu en conférence dé
aubistes en quelques mots si toi tu
devais définir la france idéale
je dirais qu cois france idéal ce serait
pour moi une france avec des citoyens
des habitants qui peuvent participer aux
décisions parce que chacun sait ce qui
est bon pour lui et pour les autres je
pense mais il faut pas penser qu'à sa
pomme évidemment donc c'est des gens qui
qui contribuerait afin faire les les
lois mais avec l'idée de l'intérêt
général
voilà on va faire la photo ici est en
fait tu vas monter un petit peu les
marches
[Musique]